congiurato le mie baby di questo nuovo
video bellissimo allora mi spiego una
roba che abbiamo fatto questa settimana
che è stata incredibile agli eventi in
collaborazione con netflix il video ve
lo lascio qua sotto perché ci hanno
hanno fatto il video ios breezer sasha e
sori abbiamo fatto takeshi's castel è
molto difficile perché la mia attività
fisica massima e fare dalla sedia al
divano ho fatto il video backstage di
tutto sto casino ve lo lascio perché
secondo me merita un sacco buona visione
ragazzi però che succede questo lontano
ma che dici giuro perché che dobbiamo
fare una cosa veramente che non è nelle
mie corde oggi spiega di mente dobbiamo
fare un allenamento di marin
praticamente nel fango terribili io è
quell'uomo lì ma è il famosissimo
surreal per quello però non è paura
soltanto sugli scudi e non possiamo fare
niente altro che soffrire tutto il
giorno ammazza che cerchi zio della
della croce rossa che cioè il telefono
pronto per il e adesso gli olivi the raw
intorno e lui mi parla da fumetti
guardami stati scommettiamo 5 euro
ma va inoltre nell'amore di gesù io la
chance a sciascia ti stai gridando il re
calore ok
eccoci tutti pronti quindi per favore è
lorenzo al momento dell'omelia perché
sembra impensabile è stanca grande
addosso loro lago paciano quatu pensi
che ci temono solo pensiamo più giovani
chiudiamola qui siamo giovani belli
sbarbati e con un sacco di iscritti
allora cp ha mentito la nato ci manda no
e anzi non possono anche finire per
essere per il collo è vero quindi ci
temono
ma voi riempì degli schermi questa
profonda l'arco è già un po troppo filo
di restare dietro la telecamera mette in
primo piano perché io sono troppo debole
nei titoli è più debole ci dobbiamo dare
una mano a vicenda
rispetto però possiamo notare in natura
un esemplare di rinoceronte sta che
passeggia in quel di buccinasco
famosissimi i rinoceronti di buccinasco
attenzione potrebbe essersi accorto di
noi sono molto ostili in situazioni
dell'umano si avvicina troppo a queste
creature ma attenzione
l'allievo anguilla un thriller giampiero
spero di rivederti anche io
anche io mi servirà per pagare l'affitto
quindi spera che non muoio infatti
infatti 32 a lui decide bocchino invece
grande
ha già vinto ma proprio interno per
frutta dettagli finale forse mi crolla
nel finale non si aiuta una vita
finalità vieni qua allora ragazzi ti
devo dire una cosa la prossima volta che
andrete in una giungla in una foresta
pluviale
mi raccomando portati di quanti li hanno
tolti perché accesso delle blatte grosse
poi più grosse del mio canale e questa è
una cosa molto difficile
quindi io lo capisco questo ragazzo non
biasima telo non importa sono abbiamo
preso il punto tanto adesso ti
sotterriamo unico demonio pesanti nacho
quindi a barre dai e l'ultimo vj vediamo
e maino sua la possibilità di vincere
finora è nato bene però l'ultimo giro di
copertone
mai ma che fa al caso ma vero che si
disunisce adesso chiede anche la
vittoria dovrebbe a ridere
ai blu vediamo si è l'ultimo campo non
lo vedremo mai più però è convinto a
suonare la campana almeno due
motivazioni per quadrare questo anzi tre
prima i confessionali che sono stati
attentissimi 2 suri è sporco in una
maniera incredibile e treccia esprit ci
sono io che è un no ci sei tu punto non
superare finito basta però voglio
veramente andare ho detto che una volta
corro all'anno la seconda basta cioè da
buttarmi nel filo spinato però sta bene
non si può mettere facendo non farla
mettere magari
[Musica]